oh  but how does that even  what kind of weed was that  because that edible i tasted the weed in  the in the edible but but right but it  wasn't gross right and then also the the  uh the tart the fruitness of it was  really really powerful it was honestly i  could have eaten two or three of them  and i've had three vodka sodas yeah so i  am what we call  some act if i didn't know who you are if  i had no idea what's going on  and you were a homeless pimp's friend  and and he introduced me to you and he  said what do you think my friend does  i'd say he's a poet  you look like a poet with the glasses  with the hair you have a poetry look  right like if you were if you would if  you would say hey  draw a haiku i would draw a cell  [Laughter]  phone  still messed up  [Applause]